MICHALE FEE: OK, so let's
go ahead and get started.
OK, so in the last
lecture, we talked
about how the inputs to neurons
actually come into a cell
mostly on the dendrite, which
is this extended arborization
of cylinders of
cell membrane that
give a very large
surface area that
allow many, many synapses to
contact onto a neuron, many
more than would be possible
if all of those synapses
were trying to connect to
this neuron on its soma.
Today, we are going to follow up
on that general picture of how
neurons receive inputs.
And today, we're going to focus
on the question of how synapses
work.
So we're going to
start by looking
at a simple model of synapses.
And we're going to
end by understanding
how synapses on different
parts of the neuron
can actually do quite
different things.
So here's our list of
learning objectives for today.
So we're going to learn how to
add a synapse to an equivalent
circuit model.
And we're going to
describe a simple model
of how that actually generates
voltage changes in a neuron
and what those synaptic
inputs actually do.
We're going to describe
mathematical process called
convolution.
That's going to allow us
to extend the idea of how
a neuron responds
to a single input
spike from a presynaptic
neuron to how a neuron responds
to multiple spikes coming
from a presynaptic neuron.
So we're going to introduce
this idea of convolution,
which I'm sure many of
you have heard of before.
But it's going to play an
increasingly important role
in the class.
And so we're going
to introduce it here.
We're going to talk about the
idea of synaptic saturation,
which is the idea that a single
synaptic input can generate
a small response in a neuron.
You would think that as you
generate more and more synaptic
inputs to a neuron
that the response
of the postsynaptic neuron
might just keep increasing.
But, in fact, the response
of a neuron to its inputs
saturates at some level.
And that process of
saturation actually
has very important
consequences for how neurons
respond to their inputs.
And then finally, we're
going to end with a fun story
about the different functions
of somatic and dendritic
inhibition.
And we're going to tell
that story in the context
of a crayfish behavior.
All right, so let's start
with chemical synapses.
There are also electrical
synapses, which
we're not going to talk about.
And that's basically where
two neurons can actually
contact each other.
There are actually proteins
that form little holes
between the neurons.
And so they're just directly
electrically connected
with each other.
That's called an electrical
synapse, or a gap junction.
We're not going to
talk about that today.
We're going to focus
on chemical synapses.
So this is the structure of
a typical excitatory synapse
from a presynaptic neuron.
This is the axon of
a presynaptic neuron
onto the dendrites of
a postsynaptic neuron.
Postsynaptic dendrites have
often these specializations
called spines, which
are just little
mushroom like protrusions of the
cell membrane of the dendrite
onto which presynaptic
neurons can form of synapse.
So this is called the
presynaptic component
or terminal.
That's the
postsynaptic component
or postsynaptic terminal.
On the presynaptic
side, there are
very small synaptic vesicles,
about 30 to 40 nanometers
in diameter, that
sort of form a cloud
or a cluster on the just
on the inside surface
of this synaptic junction.
The synapses are typically
about a half a micron across.
And the synaptic
cleft is very small.
It's about 20 nanometers.
So this is not quite to scale.
This should be maybe a
little bit closer here.
All right, notice that
that is very small.
That synapse is really tiny.
It's about the wavelength.
Its size is equal to 1
wavelength of green light.
So it's a tiny structure.
There's a lot going on inside
that little thing, though.
And here's we're going to walk
through the sequence of events
that just describes how
a presynaptic action
potential leads
to depolarization
and in a postsynaptic neuron.
So we have an action potential
that propagates down.
That's a pulse of
depolarizing voltage.
When it reaches the
synaptic terminal,
that pulse of
depolarizing voltage
is about plus 50 millivolts.
That activates voltage gated
calcium channels that turn on,
just the same way that we've
described voltage activated
sodium channels and
potassium channels.
That allows calcium ions to flow
into the presynaptic terminal.
That calcium flows in and binds
to presynaptic proteins that
dock these vesicles
onto the membrane facing
the synaptic cleft.
That causes those vesicles
to fuse with the membrane.
They open up and release
their neurotransmitters.
So all of those vesicles are
filled with neurotransmitter.
The vesicles are coated
with actual pumps that
take neurotransmitter
from inside of the cell
and pump it into the vesicles.
So then calcium flows in.
Vesicle fuses, releases
neurotransmitter
into the cleft.
Neurotransmitter then
diffuses in the cleft.
You could actually
calculate how long
it takes to get from one side
to the other now, I think.
It's not very long.
Ligand gated ion
channels, they're
basically like the
kinds of ion channels
we've already been discussing.
But instead of being
gated by voltage,
they're gated by the binding of
a neurotransmitter to a binding
site on the outside
of the protein.
That produces a
conformational change
that opens the pour
to the flow of ions.
Now, you have neurotransmitter
binds to these, opens the pour.
You have now positive ions
that flow into the cell,
because the cell
is hyperpolarized.
So it has a low voltage.
Positive ions flow
into the cell.
That corresponds to an increase
in the synaptic conductance.
What is that flow of ions,
positive ions, into the cell
do?
It depolarizes the cell.
You have synaptic current
flowing in that then--
I forget to put it on there--
depolarizes the cell.
Any questions about that?
OK, let's talk a little
bit about the sort of some
of the interesting numbers, like
how many synapses there are,
how many cells, how many
dendrites in a little piece
of neural tissue.
It's pretty staggering actually.
So the synopses are small.
But what's really amazing is
that in a cubic millimeter
of cortical tissue, there
are a billion synapses.
And if you think
about what that means,
there is a synapse on a grid,
on a lattice, every 1.1 microns.
So they're sort of some
fraction of a micron big.
And there's one of
them every micron.
Most of your brain is
filled with synapses.
There are 4.1 kilometers of axon
in that same cubic millimeter
and 500 meters of dendrite.
A typical cortical cell
receives about 10,000 synapses.
Each cell has about 4
millimeters of dendrite
and 4 centimeters of axon.
And there are about 10 to the
5 neurons per cubic millimeter
in the mouse cortex.
And in your entire
brain, there are about 10
of the 8 neurons, which is
the same roughly as the number
of stars in our galaxy.
And we're going to
figure out how it works.
OK, so let's come back to this.
So let's start by adding
a synapse to an equivalent
circuit model and understanding
how that model works.
So let's start with an
ionotropic receptor.
So ionotropic receptors are
neurotransmitter receptors
that also form an ion channel.
There are other kinds of
neurotransmitter receptors
where a neurotransmitter binds.
And that sends a
chemical signal that
opens up a different
kind of ion channel.
Those are called metabotropic
neurotransmitter receptors.
We're going to focus today
on ionotropic receptors.
So a neurotransmitter binds.
That binding opens a gate.
And that allows a
current to flow.
So these guys,
Magleby and Stevens,
did an experiment to understand
how that conductance--
so when that ion channel opens,
it turns on a conductance.
And you can directly
measure that conductance
by doing a voltage
clamp experiment.
So here's the
experiment they did.
They took a muscle
fiber from a frog.
They set up a
voltage clamp on it,
so an electrode to
measure the voltage,
and another electrode
to inject current.
You hold the voltage
at different levels.
And then what they did was
they stimulated electrically
the motor axon, the
axon of the motor neuron
that innervates the muscle.
So that then activates
this neuromuscular junction
that opens
acetylcholine receptors
and produces a current
as a function of time
after the synapse is activated.
Any questions about the setup?
We're simply holding the
cell at different voltages,
activating the synapse, and
measuring how much current
flows through the synapse.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So with the
current flows through the ion
channels in the muscle fibers?
MICHALE FEE: The current is
flowing through these ion
channels here in the synapse.
Now, remember,
there are all sorts
of sodium channels and potassium
channels and all those things.
But do those do anything?
AUDIENCE: Not really.
MICHALE FEE: We're just
holding the voltage-- that's
why the voltage is so
important, because if you were
to do this experiment without
a voltage, you would stimulate
and the muscle would contract.
And it would rip the electrodes
out of the muscle fiber.
So when you voltage clamp
it, it holds the cell
at a constant potential,
so that the cell
can't spike when the current
flows in through the synapse.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: On the graph,
would the shock [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes, the shock--
AUDIENCE: The difference is
like in positive and negative--
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, I'm
going to explain this.
I'm just setting
it up right now.
OK, any questions
about the setup?
Good questions.
One step ahead of me.
All right, so now, let's look
at what actually happens.
So what you can see is
that the current that
goes through these ion
channels is different
depending on the voltage
that you hold the cell at.
So if you hold the cell
at a negative potential--
so here you can see, the voltage
it is like minus 120 here.
And what happens
is after you shock,
you see this large,
inward current.
Remember, inward current,
negative current corresponds
to positive ions going into
the cell, inward current.
So after you activate
the motor axon,
you get a large
inward current that
lasts a couple milliseconds.
That corresponds
to current going
into the cell that would
depolarize the cell
and activate it, right?
But as you raise
the voltage, you
can see that the
current gets smaller.
And at some point, the
current actually goes to zero.
And it goes to zero
when you are holding
the membrane potential
close to zero.
And as you hold the membrane
potential more positive,
you can see that the current
actually goes the other way.
So what we can do is we can
now plot that peak current
as a function of the
holding potential.
So we're measuring
current through an ion
channel at different voltages.
So what are we
going to plot next?
Just like we did for
the sodium channel,
for the potassium channel,
we're going to-- what
are we going to plot?
What kind of plot?
AUDIENCE: I-V.
MICHALE FEE: An I-V curve.
Excellent.
Let's do that.
You can see it's
actually linear.
So the current is negative when
you hold the cell negative.
The current's positive when
you hold the cell above zero.
And it crosses at zero.
What do we call that place
where it crosses zero?
What does that tell us?
When this ion channel is open--
AUDIENCE: Reversal potential.
MICHALE FEE: So
reversal potential
or the equilibrium
potential, that's right.
That's kind of weird, right?
An equilibrium
potential that's zero.
What kind of channel has an
equilibrium potential at zero?
Remember, sodium was very
negative, like minus 80--
sorry, potassium
was very negative.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Excellent.
It's something that passes
both potassium and sodium.
It's like a hole.
So this ion channel is
basically like opening
a hole that passes positive
ions in both directions.
Potassium goes out,
sodium comes in.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: But that is only
like [INAUDIBLE] before the--
MICHALE FEE: Notice
that we're plotting
that the current as
a function of all
voltages, and it
crosses at zero.
There's zero current at zero
voltage, which happens when you
have just a non-selective pore.
OK, what does that look like?
An I-V curve that looks
like that, what is that?
There's a name for that.
You use it when you
build a circuit.
You might have some transistors
and some capacitors and some--
how about some resistors?
It's just a resistor.
That's what the I-V curve
of a resistor looks like.
And if we were to
put it in series
with a battery, what would
the voltage of the battery be?
Zero.
Remember, if we put it
in series with a battery,
it produces an offset.
So it's just our same equation--
the current is just a
conductance times a voltage.
It's just Ohm's law.
That's 1 over resistance.
And it's V minus e synaptic.
And e synaptic is just 0.
So that's called the
driving potential.
That's the conductance.
Can anyone take a guess at
what the conductance looks
like as a function of time?
Somebody just hold
your hand up, and--
I see two answers
that are very close.
Lena.
AUDIENCE: Would it be like that?
MICHALE FEE: Start over here.
Like go this way.
What would the conductance
do as a function of time
to make the current
look like this?
What would it be here?
What would the
conductance be here?
Remember, the voltage is
being held at some value.
The current is zero.
So the conductance must be?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
MICHALE FEE: Zero.
And how about here?
It should be some
big conductance.
And then what about here?
AUDIENCE: Zero.
MICHALE FEE: Zero.
So what is that-- excellent,
it just looks like that.
The conductance just turns
on and then turns off.
Anybody want to take a
guess at why that might be?
Shock.
What happens here?
Why does this turn on?
Because neurotransmitter
binds to the receptor,
opens the channel.
And then what happens?
The neurotransmitter falls off.
And the neurotransmitter
receptor closes.
That's it.
We're going to do a little
bit of mathematical modeling
of that.
But it's going to
be pretty simple.
All right?
OK.
So there is our
equivalent circuit.
This thing right here
equals conductance times
of driving potential
electrically is just that.
You remember that, right?
That's the same way we modeled
the current of the sodium
channel or the
potassium channel.
AUDIENCE: So the
graphical [INAUDIBLE]
because it's linear, why
would that [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: The
conductance constant?
AUDIENCE: Yeah
MICHALE FEE: OK.
Because look at the current.
So, remember, these
different voltages
here just correspond
to these voltages.
Here V minus E sin.
So E sin is what?
The synaptic reversal
potential is just zero, right?
So for each one of
these experiments,
this driving potential
is just constant.
It's just given by this holding
potential in the voltage kind
of experiment.
So in order to
turn something that
looks like this into something
that looks like this,
you have to multiply it by
something that looks like that.
Does that makes sense?
For each one of
those experiments,
this term is constant.
And so to get a current
that looks like this,
the conductance has
to look like that.
Does that makes sense?
AUDIENCE: guess she's
asking the upper--
MICHALE FEE: Oh, sorry, did
I misunderstand the question?
Ask it again.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I was talking about that one.
MICHALE FEE: Oh.
AUDIENCE: But explanation
did make sense.
MICHALE FEE: Did it help?
But it was the
wrong explanation.
OK, so ask your question again.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so I
was trying to relate it
to what we were doing earlier
with a [? coefficient ?]
[INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And it had an I-V
curve that looked something
like that curve--
MICHALE FEE: Oh, it like had
some funny shape like this.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it looked
like [INAUDIBLE] at zero.
And then it was like--
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, so remember,
this is as a function of time.
And this is exactly what the
sodium conductance looked
like as a function of time.
It turns on.
And then it turns off.
For the sodium conductance,
this turning on
happened with a voltage step.
And the turning off happened
because of the inactivation
gate.
In this case, it's different.
What's turning this thing on
is a neurotransmitter binding
that turns it off.
And what turns it off
is not inactivation.
It's the fact that the
neurotransmitter falls off.
But it has the same
time dependence.
It's just different mechanisms.
And then for this, was there
a question still about this?
AUDIENCE: No.
[INAUDIBLE] using
that with the--
MICHALE FEE: Oh, with
the tie-- it was, OK--
and you understand why this
doesn't look like this, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHALE FEE: The
reason that happened
is because it looked
like this for most of it,
but it went back down to 0 here
as a function of voltage y.
Because of the
voltage dependence
shuts the [AUDIO OUT]
off down here,
this doesn't have
voltage dependent.
It's cool how all this
stuff ties together, right?
It's sort of the same stuff we
learned for the Hodgkin Huxley,
just applies to this case here.
All right, so
there's the circuit.
Here's the model that
we described before.
There's a simple soma with
a capacitance and some leak
conductance.
And now that is
how we would model
attaching a synapse, any kind
of a synapse, onto a soma.
And if we wanted the
some to be able to spike,
we would add some potassium,
some voltage dependent
potassium and some
voltage dependent sodium.
All right, any questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I probably should
have asked this a long time ago
and not [INAUDIBLE] circuit.
Do you know whether to have
the big line of the battery--
MICHALE FEE: Oh, yeah, so that's
not a dumb question at all.
The answer is don't
worry about it.
Like there's a convention that
the big one is the plus side.
And I'm not even 100% sure
I've been perfectly consistent
in all my slides.
The long line is supposed
to be the positive side
of the battery.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Just don't worry.
Just make one big and one small.
And don't-- just make
it a battery symbol.
And I don't care if
it's the right way.
OK.
OK?
You don't want to make it
too much like a capacitor,
because if they're
the same length, then
it looks like a capacitor.
And if you're worried just draw
an arrow and write battery.
OK?
All right, good.
OK, so now, let's step back from
our voltage clamp of experiment
and attach this synapse
to a real neuron,
like this thing, the
one that can't spike.
It's just a leaky soma
that's hyperpolarized.
And now, what's the voltage
in the cell going to do
when we activate that synapse.
What is the voltage here?
We're turning on
this conductance.
What that's means is
we're making distance
get really small.
So what is the voltage
inside the cell going to do?
It's going to
approach something.
What's it going to approach?
We have this circuit.
We have a battery
and a resistor.
Let's make that resistor
really, really big.
That connects the battery
between the outside and inside
of our neuron.
And now we make the resistor
really small all of a sudden.
What's going to happen
to the voltage in here?
AUDIENCE: What is G I?
MICHALE FEE: Sorry, just
some other conductance.
And let's just imagine that
it's like potassium conductance
that's kind of holding
the cell hyperpolarized.
But I don't want you to
focus on this right now.
What I want you to
focus on is what
would happen here when I
turn on that synapse, when
I make the resistor
really small,
when I make the
conductance really big.
What's going to happen to
the voltage inside the cell?
It's going to
approach something.
It's going to be dragged
toward something.
It's going to be dragged toward
the voltage of that battery.
We're hooking that battery up
to the inside of our neuron.
Does that makes sense?
OK, so that's what I'm
going to show you now.
So if we have an
excitatory synapse--
so what I'm going
to show you is what
happens when we activate
a glutamatergic excitatory
synapse on a cell.
We're going to record
the voltage in the cell.
And we're going to
activate that synapse.
And what you see is
that this is what
you would see, for example,
for the muscle fiber.
You activate the
synapse, and you see
that the voltage of the cell--
if the cell is hyperpolarized,
the voltage of the cell
goes up.
If you hold the cell
at a higher voltage,
the voltage also goes up,
but a little bit less.
If you hold the
cell at zero, you
can see you activate
that synapse,
but the cell is already at
the potential of the battery.
And so there's no current
and no change in the voltage.
If you hold the cell
at a positive voltage,
and you activate the
synapse, again, you're
connecting the cell to a
battery that has 0 volts.
And so the voltage goes down.
So here's what I
want to convey here,
that when you activate a
synapse, it forces the cell,
forces the voltage in
the cell, to approach
the voltage of the reversal
potential of the synapse,
the voltage of that battery.
Is that clear?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: It increases
the conductance.
Current flows into this cell.
And it flows into the
cell in a direction
so that the voltage of
approaches the equilibrium
potential.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
MICHALE FEE: Ah, yes, good.
In fact, that's a
great way to phrase it,
because that kind
of experiment here
where we're measuring the
voltage inside the cell
is called current
clamp experiment.
So there's voltage
clamp, where you
force the voltage to be
constant by varying the current.
Here, we're holding the current
constant, clamping the current,
and measuring the voltage.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, let's
just go back to the setup
here, this experiment here.
You don't you don't
set it up like this.
You set it up like we had
on the first day of class,
where you just have a
current source connected here
and a volt meter attached
to this electrode.
I didn't use that word.
But that was the very
first experiment we did.
I think on the
second day of class,
we had a cell with a
electrode to inject current,
electrode to measure voltage.
That was a current
clamp experiment,
because we're holding the
current at some constant value.
OK?
Here, we're holding the
voltage at some constant value
and measuring current.
All right, so the
idea is really simple,
when you have a
synapse, the synapse
has a reversal potential.
When you activate
the synapse, the cell
is dragged toward the
reversal potential.
Here, the reversal
potential was zero.
So when I activate the
synapse, the voltage
goes toward the
reversal potential.
Notice-- yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, just a
very basic question.
So is [INAUDIBLE] the top
half is like the synaptic face
of the circuit and the
bottom half is like--
MICHALE FEE: Are you talking
about like here versus here?
Yeah, so I've put that pink
box around the synapse.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHALE FEE: That's
the circuit that
corresponds to having a
synapse attached to the cell.
And this is the circuit that
we developed several weeks ago.
AUDIENCE: OK.
But it's acting like
the presynaptic--
like a cell or--
MICHALE FEE: Oh, no,
the presynaptic cell
is not part of this picture.
The presynaptic cell is kind of
like spritzing neurotransmitter
onto this thing, which
increases the conductance, which
is the same as reducing
the size of a resistor.
Does that makes sense?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So is the reversal
potential always going
to be zero or like just like
in this specific example?
MICHALE FEE: Great question.
So the reversal potential is
different for different kinds
of synapses.
You can see that this
synapse, this kind of synapse
here, if I'm hyperpolarized, it
pushes the voltage of the cell
up.
What kind of synapse
do you think that is?
An excitatory synapse.
But notice something
really cool.
An excitatory synapse
doesn't always
push the voltage of the cell up.
If the cell is
sitting up here, it
can push the voltage
of the cell down.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why doesn't
it just stay up?
MICHALE FEE: Why?
Great.
So great question.
You can probably
answer that already.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's some--
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm hearing a bunch
of good answers.
So what happens is we're
stimulating the synapse here,
releases neurotransmitter.
The conductance goes up.
Current flows in,
depolarizes the cell,
neurotransmitter unbinds.
Current stops.
And this thing brings
the cell back down
to its starting point,
this other thing.
Yeah, this thing is
kind of holding the cell
at some hyperpolarized
potential.
AUDIENCE: So even though
they've lost a current.
MICHALE FEE: The current is
turning on and then turning
off.
Remember, the current--
here it is right here--
the current is turning on
as the conductance turns on.
And then when the
conductance goes to zero,
the current goes to zero.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I thought it
was a big current clamp.
MICHALE FEE: No.
The experiment we're doing
is injecting constant current
into the cell.
And that's how we hold the cell
at these different sort of kind
of average voltages.
OK, maybe I should say-- yes.
AUDIENCE: So I just [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Makes it do this?
AUDIENCE: Well, I don't
understand how that changes.
I just always want
positive ions to flow in.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
So positive ions
flowing into the cell
raise the voltage in this.
AUDIENCE: But I don't
understand if the inside
of cell is already positive,
why adding more positive--
MICHALE FEE: Oh.
OK, great question.
You're talking about up here.
OK, so let me just back up and
explain one thing that maybe I
didn't explain very well.
In this experiment,
we're injecting current
through our current
electrode to just hold
the cell at different voltages
while we stimulate the synapse.
Does that makes sense?
Down here, let's say, we're
not injecting any current.
And then we inject a
little bit of current
to kind of hold
the cell up here.
And we activate the synapse
and measure changes from there.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: So when
it's a current clamp,
it just leaves the
input the same?
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
You're just turning
a knob and saying
I'm going to put in 1 nanoamp.
And that's just going to kind
of hold the cell up here.
And then I activate
the synapse and ask
how does the voltage change.
OK?
Oh.
AUDIENCE: That's
not my question.
MICHALE FEE: I know.
AUDIENCE: My question--
MICHALE FEE: But I
realized-- your question
is why does this go down?
AUDIENCE: Like I
thought that's--
MICHALE FEE: Yeah.
Exactly.
Isn't that cool?
Excitatory synapses are
not always inject-- so
what happens up here?
You're holding the cell up here.
And now you activate
the synapse.
And the voltage
actually goes down.
And the answer is
that if you're holding
this cell up here positive,
more positive than here,
when you turn on
that conductance,
the current goes the other way.
AUDIENCE: Passed the
reversal potential.
MICHALE FEE: So you've passed
the reversal potential.
You're holding the cell up here.
And so [AUDIO OUT]
turn on the synapse,
the current flows
the other direction.
You have a positive
current, which
is positive ions
flowing out, which
lowers the voltage of the cell.
So the way to
think about this is
that when you have a synapse,
you turn the synapse on,
it doesn't matter
where the voltage is,
it's always driving it toward
the reversal potential.
And if you start above
the reversal potential,
the voltage will go down.
If you start below the
reversal potential,
the voltage will go up.
It's like not what you
learned in 901, right?
AUDIENCE: No.
MICHALE FEE: This is--
yeah.
But this is how it really works.
OK?
Excitatory synapses,
the reason you
think of excitatory synapses as
always pushing the voltage up
is because most of
the time, the cell
is sitting [AUDIO OUT] here.
But this is going to become much
more important and obvious when
we're talking about
inhibitory synapses.
So let's talk about
inhibitory segments.
So here's a model with the
synaptic reversal at zero.
All excitatory synapses have
their reversal potential
around zero.
The neuromuscular junction,
the glutamatergic synapse,
they're all basically
non-specific
pores that have a reversal
potential of zero.
Inhibitory synapses
are different.
So excitatory-- the
reason we call it
an excitatory synapse is
because that reversal potential
is above the threshold
for the neuron to spike.
And so when you
activate the synapse,
you're pushing the
voltage of the cell
always toward a voltage that's
above the spiking threshold.
That's why it's called
an excitatory synapse.
And those are called excitatory
postsynaptic potentials,
or EPSP.
That little bump is an EPSP.
All right, now, inhibitory
synapses look really different.
And now the effect that I'm
talking about is important.
With an inhibitory synapse,
the reversal potential
is around minus 75.
Remember, most inhibitory
synapses are chloride channels.
And chloride, do you
remember on the lecture
about the equilibrium
potentials?
The reversal potential
for chloride channels
is around minus 75.
And that's why the synaptic
reversal potential is minus 75.
And now, you can see that
if you hold the cell--
so here's where a
cell normally sits.
You activate the synapse.
The voltage goes down.
All right.
And why does it go down?
Because it's pulled
toward the equilibrium
potential for the chloride
channel, chloride ion.
Now, notice that--
OK, so as the cell is
more and more depolarized,
you can see that
it's more strongly
pulled toward [AUDIO OUT]
the voltage change is bigger.
If you hold the
cell at minus 75,
there's no voltage change
at all from activating
an inhibitory synapse.
And if you hyperpolarize
the cell even more,
you can see that
when you activate
an inhibitory synapse
the voltage of the cell
actually goes up.
So inhibitory
synapses don't always
make the potential
of the cell go down.
In fact, sometimes they
can make this cell go up.
In fact, what's really cool
is in juvenile animals,
the chloride reversal
potential, there's
more chloride inside of a cell
than there is in an adult.
And so the reversal potential
of the chloride channels
is actually up here.
And chloride inhibitory
synapses can actually
make neurons spike.
You can see where
this thing sits.
It just depends on the
concentration of chloride ions.
Most of the time
inhibitory synapses
have a reversal potential
that's minus 75.
And we call that inhibitory
because the reversal potential
of the synapse is less
than the spiking threshold.
AUDIENCE: What [INAUDIBLE]
reversal potential?
MICHALE FEE: Just the--
OK, you know the answer
to that question.
You tell me.
So what are the two things--
yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The type of ion.
MICHALE FEE: Good.
The type of iron.
And one more thing.
There were two things we need
to have a battery in a neuron.
What are they?
Anybody know?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: And?
MICHALE FEE: Ion
selective permeability.
So the reversal
potential depends
on what ion that
channel is selective for
and the concentrations
of that ion
inside and outside the cell.
So for an inhibitory
synapse, there are two types.
There are chloride
reversal potentials,
the chloride channels that have
a reverse potential minus 75.
And there are also
potassium channels
that serve an
inhibitory function that
can be activated by synapses.
And they have a reversal
potential more like minus 80.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
develop [INAUDIBLE] it's
not chloride channel
is not changing.
So what the ion channel--
MICHALE FEE: It's
the ion concen--
AUDIENCE: Change so the--
MICHALE FEE: The concentration
that's different.
OK?
Cool.
You see this kind of
stuff all the time.
Inhibitory
postsynaptic potentials
are often upward going.
Somebody will be super
impressed with you
if you look at a trace
like this and you say,
is that an EPSP or an IPSP?
Because you don't know
it just by looking at it.
Most people would
assume it's an EPSP.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Was [INAUDIBLE]
to cause like a spike?
MICHALE FEE: Well,
so what do you think?
It's inhibitory if the
reversal potential [INAUDIBLE]
in the threshold.
So no matter how strong
that inhibitory synapse is,
can it ever cause a spike
if the reversal potential
is less than the threshold?
All right, let's go on.
Any questions about this.
It's so fundamental.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
potential [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: So it's normally
around minus 60 minus
[AUDIO OUT] minus 75.
OK?
OK, let's go on.
All right, let me just
talk a little bit more
about this conductance.
So if you do a single
channel patch experiment,
you can take an electrode.
Remember, I showed
you what it looks
like if you take an
electrode and you stick it
on a single sodium channel or
a single potassium channel.
Well, you can do the same thing.
You can stick it on a
neurotransmitter receptor.
You can flow neurotransmitter
over the receptor.
And what you see is that when
you put the neurotransmitter
on, just like sodium
and potassium channels,
it flickers between an open
state and a closed state.
So it has two states--
open state and closed state.
You can do the same
kind of modeling of it
as where the kinetic rate
equation with two states.
You can write down
the probability
that the channel is in the
open and closed states.
That's going to be
a function of what?
Like neurotransmitter
concentration and time, right?
And you can write down the
total synaptic conductance
as the conductance of a
single open neurotransmitter
receptor times the number
of neurotransmitter
receptors times the probability
that any of them is open,
any one of them is open.
And so now, let's think
about this probability
as a function of time.
So we can model the
neurotransmitter receptors
and write down the
probability that it's open.
The probability that's closed,
then has to be 1 minus p.
Alpha and beta are
rate constants.
1 over time, they have
units of 1 over time.
And what controls the rate
at which the channels open?
Good.
So alpha will depend
on the concentration
of neurotransmitter.
That controls the rate at
which closed channels open.
And how about open to closed?
It's not the concentration
of the neurotransmitter.
It'll be something else.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Exactly.
So there will be
basically some rate
constant for a
neurotransmitter unwinding.
OK?
All right, so let's do that.
So here's that model.
This is a simplified version
of the Magleby-Stevens model.
And it looks like this.
There's a close
and an open state.
The open state corresponds to
the closed neurotransmitter
receptor R binding to
a neurotransmitter,
an unbound
neurotransmitter molecule,
forming a complex,
bound receptor complex.
There's usually another step--
the way this is usually modeled
in the Magleby-Stevens model
is that the bound
receptor complex is closed
and then it opens in
another transition.
But we're just going to keep
it simple and do it this way.
So we have a closed state
unbound neurotransmitter
receptor binds to an unbound
neurotransmitter's receptor
molecule and forms our
bound receptor complex
that is then open.
So that's P. And
that's 1 minus P.
And we can just write down
the rate equation just
the same way that we
did for analyze the time
dependence of the sodium channel
or the potassium channel.
Isn't that amazing?
All that stuff we learned
for Hodgkin-Huxley,
just you can use all
the same machinery here.
OK?
OK, so that's a simple model.
And you can take a
simplification of it.
We're going to assume that
the binding is very fast,
that the alpha is very fast.
So that when you put a pulse of
neurotransmitter concentration
onto the synapse, the
probability of being open,
we're going to assume
that this is super fast.
So that the rate at which
you go from unbound to bound
is very high.
And now, the
neurotransmitter goes away.
And you can see zero
concentration here.
Let's say you bind, the
probability of being open
gets big.
And then the
neurotransmitter goes away.
You can see that
this first term goes
to 0, because the
neurotransmitter
concentration is zero.
You can see that dP/dt
is just minus beta P.
And that's just an
exponential decay.
So the model is bind
neurotransmitter
opens the
neurotransmitter receptor.
Neurotransmitter goes away.
And then there's an
exponential decay probability
that you're in the open state.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So like
in a real synapse,
the neurotransmitter
wouldn't like go away, right?
MICHALE FEE: What's that?
Oh, yeah, the
neurotransmitter goes away.
I forgot to say that.
It's a super important point.
There's one more step
that I forgot to include.
Habib is nodding at me
like, yeah you forgot that.
What happens is the
neurotransmitter
goes into the cleft.
And it gets taken up
by neurotransmitter--
what they called again, Habib?
AUDIENCE: Reuptake.
MICHALE FEE: Reuptake.
Thank you.
That neurotransmitter
gets bound by receptors
on glia and the
presynaptic terminal
and gets pumped out
of the synaptic cleft.
So that's what makes this go
away, in addition to diffusion.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
like the time dependence
of the concentration--
MICHALE FEE: So this is--
in the full model you do.
And, in fact, what
this really looks
like is this kind of turns on
more slowly and then goes away
with an exponential.
But I'm just kind of walking you
through this super simplified
model.
That's my mental model
for how synapse works.
OK?
People who actually
work on synapses
would probably laugh
at me, but that's
kind of how I think of it.
OK?
Lena.
AUDIENCE: Is that
N the binding site?
MICHALE FEE: Oh, yeah, the
N, the N is really cool.
What do you think it means?
AUDIENCE: Binding sites?
MICHALE FEE: Yes, it's the
number of binding sites.
So you can see that if
the receptor requires
two neurotransmitter molecules
to bind before it opens, then
you have a
concentration squared.
And that has really important
consequences on the way
it works, because
what it does is
it makes the receptor
very sensitive
to high concentrations
of neurotransmitter.
So they don't respond
to the little leakage
of some residual
neurotransmitter left around
that the reuptake systems
haven't dealt with yet.
But when a vessel
releases, then you
have a neurotransmitter at
a very high concentration.
And this thing makes it
only sensitive to the peak
of the neurotransmitter
concentration.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: With the
probably [INAUDIBLE]
number of [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Here.
In this phase,
does this N matter?
Is that your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, well,
so you know the answer
to that question.
Here, you're asking if
here this N matters?
What's that concentration here?
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's 0.
MICHALE FEE: So
what's 0 to the N?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: 0.
OK, next, so we just
did all of that.
I better speed up.
Let's talk about convolution.
So this is what happens
when a single action
potential comes down the axon.
The presynaptic terminal
releases neurotransmitter.
Boom, you get a pulse of
probability of the receptor
being open.
That, you recall, is
just proportional--
yikes, where'd it go.
That probability is you just
multiply it by some constants
to get the conductance.
So that is what the
conductance looks like.
OK?
All right, now, so
there's our input spike.
Our input neuron, our
presynaptic neuron
generates a spike.
And that produces
a response, which
is a conductance that
looks like a pulse
and an exponential decay.
OK?
Now, what do you
think would happen
if [AUDIO OUT] a bunch
of spikes like this?
Good.
Just does it each time.
OK?
And we're ignoring fancy effects
like paired pulse depression
or facilitation or
things like that.
OK?
There are all kinds
of interesting things
that synapses can do
where there's one pulse
and then there's some
residual calcium left
in the presynaptic terminal.
And that makes the
next pulse produce
an even bigger response.
Or sometimes one pulse will
use up all the vesicles
that are bound.
And so the next
pulse will come in
and there won't
be enough vesicles
and this will be smaller.
We're just going to ignore
all of those complications
right now.
And we're just going
to think about how
to model a postsynaptic response
given a presynaptic input.
And we're going to use
what's called a linear model.
We're going to use convolution.
And we're going to call this
single event right here,
we're going to call that
the impulse response.
The input is an impulse.
And the response is
the impulse response.
And this is also
called a linear kernel.
The response to
multiple inputs can
be modeled as a convolution.
It looks a little messy.
But I'm going to explain how to
just visualize it very simply.
All right?
So here's how you
think about it.
Notice that the
response of the system
is just this
operation where we're
multiplying the kernel
times the stimulus
and integrating over time.
OK?
So what we're going to do is--
the way to think about this
is to take the kernel K,
flip it [AUDIO OUT]
wards and plot it there.
OK?
Now notice that
what this thing does
is it says I'm
going to integrate
the product of the
kernel and the stimulus--
notice I'm integrating over tau.
But this [AUDIO OUT] tau
and that has a minus tau.
So what I'm doing is I'm
multiplying at a particular--
and notice that it's
shifted by time t.
OK?
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to put the kernel at time t.
And I'm going to
integrate the product
of the kernel and the stimulus.
So what do I get if I
multiply this times this?
AUDIENCE: 0.
MICHALE FEE: 0.
And so at that time,
I write down a zero.
OK?
Now, I'm going to change t.
And I'm going to shift this
over and multiply them together.
What do I get?
Good.
Another 0.
Now let's shift it again.
I'm just increasing t here.
I'm not integrating over t.
I'm integrating over tau.
So I just shift
this a little bit.
Good.
And now when I multiply them
together, what do I get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Like
that [AUDIO OUT] good.
I just get the area under
that curve, and integrate.
And I get a point here.
Now, let's shift it again.
Good.
Now, multiply them together.
What do I get?
Slightly smaller integral.
And I plot that there.
OK?
Shift it again.
Integrate.
Plot another point.
Shift it again.
Integrate.
And if I keep shifting,
the product is 0
and the integral is 0.
OK, so you can see that
I can take this kernel,
convolve it with a
stimulus that's an impulse.
And I get the kernel.
I get the impulse response.
Does that makes sense?
So you can see what I'm
doing here is from time I'm
taking the stimulus at time t.
And as I integrate over tau,
I'm going backwards here,
and I'm going forwards here.
So starting from here,
I'm integrating like this.
I'm multiplying these like this.
And then integrating.
OK?
And that's why you flip it over.
So it's very easy to
picture what it does.
So when somebody shows
you a linear kernel
and asks you to convolve
it with a stimulus,
the first thing you do is you
just mentally flip it backwards
and slide it over
this [AUDIO OUT]
and integrate the product
at each different position.
OK?
Now, you can see that when
you do that, when you convolve
that kernel with
a pulse, you just
recover the impulse response.
OK?
So now, let's convolve linear
[AUDIO OUT] I'm plotting it
flipped backwards now--
with a single pulse.
So Daniel made these
little demos for us.
And the resulting
conductance is here.
OK?
Now, that was really
obvious and easy, right?
We didn't need to have a Matlab
program simulate that for us,
right?
But what about this?
Here, we have a spike train.
There's the postsynaptic
response from one spike.
Now, to get the
postsynaptic response
from a bunch of spikes, we
can just convolve the kernel
with this spike train.
And let's see what happens.
Boom.
Response from the first spike.
Boom, boom, boom.
OK?
And that is actually
really, really close to
what it looks like when a train
of pulses comes into a neuron.
OK?
What happens is the
first spike produces
a conductance response.
When you have two
spikes close together,
the conductance
from the first spike
has not decayed yet when
the second spike hits.
And so that comes
in and adds to it.
And it adds linearly.
So if this is halfway down,
you add a full impulse response
on top of it.
And now the previous
one and the current one
are decaying back to zero.
And you can add as many of
those on top of each other
as you want.
And it turns out this is
super easy to do in Matlab.
You're going to
learn how to do this.
This idea is so fundamental.
This idea of
convolution, we're going
to use to describe
receptive fields.
We're going to
use it to describe
filtering when we start
getting to processing data.
It's incredibly useful
and very powerful.
OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: This
linear kernel reflects
that response, the
conductance response,
of the postsynaptic
neuron to a single spike,
single presynaptic spike.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Because
if you have a bunch
of single spikes
like this, the answer
is really obvious, right?
It's just one of those, one
of those little exponentials
for every spike that comes in.
But it's less obvious when
you have a complex spike
train like this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
on top of that.
So it's just [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yeah,
the linear convolution
tells you how the
postsynaptic neuron
is going to respond to a
train of action potentials
that are overlapped, where
the response has not gone away
to the first spike by the
time the second spike arrives.
AUDIENCE: So because the kernel
can have like different shapes.
MICHALE FEE: Yeah, the kernel
can have different shapes.
I've just chosen a
particularly simple one,
because actually an
exponentially decaying kernel
turns out to be
really important.
It's actually a low pass filter.
AUDIENCE: So be it's
a linear [INAUDIBLE]
MICHALE FEE: Yes.
The convolution, if you use the
convolution, the thing you're
using as the kernel is
always a linear kernel,
because the convolution
is a linear function,
you call the thing that you
convolving a linear kernel.
It's just terminology.
AUDIENCE: OK.
MICHALE FEE: Just focus on
what it does and how it works,
rather than the names.
Just call it impulse
response if that's easier.
OK?
All right, let's push on.
I want to introduce an idea
of synaptic saturation.
And I'm getting really
worried about the crayfish.
OK, synaptic saturation.
OK, so remember, we
introduced the idea
of a two-compartment model.
So last time we talked
about a model in which
you have a soma and a dendrite.
And you simplify the dendrites
just by writing it down
as another little
piece of membrane
or another little cellular
compartment that's connected
to the soma through a resistor.
And now, you can write a model
for the dendritic compartment
that looks just like a
capacitor and a conductance
with a reversal potential.
And you have the
same kind of model--
capacitor, conductance,
reversal potential, battery--
for the soma.
And, of course, those
two compartments
are connected to each
[AUDIO OUT] resistor that
represents the axial resistance
of the piece of dendrite
that's really connecting.
OK?
So that's called a
two-compartment model.
And what we're
going to do is just
think briefly about
how to think about what
this looks like when you add
a synapse to the dendrite.
OK?
And what we're going
to study is how
the voltage in the
dendrite changes
as a function of the
amount of excitatory
conductance that you add.
So we're going to start by--
we're doing steady state.
So we don't need to worry
about our capacitor.
So we can actually just
unsolder them and take them out
of our circuit.
And we're going to study
the voltage response
in the dendrite.
So we're going to also
throw away our soma
and just ask, how does
the dendrite respond
to this synaptic input as
a function of the amount
of excitatory conductance?
And what I'm going to show you
is just that the voltage change
in the dendrite with zero
inductance, of course,
it's sitting there at the
potassium reversal potential,
or e leak.
And as you add
conductance, it corresponds
to making that
conductance, bigger
making that resistor smaller.
You're basically
attaching the battery
to the inside of the cell.
And you can see
that what happens
is as you add more
and more conductance,
as you put more and
more neurotransmitter
onto that receptor, or have
more and more neurotransmitter
receptors, the voltage response
goes up and then saturates.
And it's really obvious
why that happens, right?
Once this resistor
gets small enough,
meaning you've added
enough conductance,
the inside of the cell is
connected to the battery.
And the voltage inside the
cell just can't go any higher.
It is forced to E
synaptics, the reversal
potential of the synapse.
And it can't go any higher.
And that's why no matter how
much excitatory conductance you
add, the voltage inside the
dendrite cannot go above E
synapse.
And that's called
synaptic saturation.
And I was going to show
you the derivation of this.
It's just very simple.
You just write down
Kirchhoff's current law,
substitute the equation for
synaptic current, leak current,
solve for voltage as a
function of G synapse.
And you can write down an
approximation for the case of G
synapse much
smaller than G leak.
And what you find
is it's linear.
And so there's a
linear part [AUDIO OUT]
voltage change at
small conductances.
And you can write
down an approximation
at high synaptic conductance.
And you show that
it approaches--
the voltage
approaches E synapse.
OK, so I'm not going
to go through the math.
But it's there.
You don't have to be able
to derive it yourself.
But what I want
you to understand
is that for small
synaptic conductance,
the voltage responds linearly.
But for high synaptic
conductance, it saturates.
OK?
All right, and now,
I want to tell you
a story about inhibition.
And the basic story is that
we can add inhibition to--
so in real neurons in the
brain, inhibition sometimes
connects to dendrites.
And sometimes inhibitory
synapses connect to somata.
And they're actually different
kinds of inhibitory neurons
that preferentially connect
onto dendrites and others that
preferentially connect
onto the somata.
And it turns out there's
a really interesting story
about how that inhibition has
a different effect whether it's
connected to the dendrite or
connected to the soma, right?
So you see what I've done here.
I've got a dendrite that
has an excitatory synapse.
That's here.
And it has an
inhibitory synapse.
Or-- so we can
analyze this case--
or we consider the case where
the excitatory synapse is still
on the dendrite, but
the inhibitory synapse
comes onto the soma.
And it turns out
those two things
do something very interesting.
And this was first
shown in the crayfish.
The crayfish is a really
cool model system,
because it has very
stereotyped behaviors.
And one of its interesting
stereotyped behaviors
is its escape reflexes.
It has three different
kinds of escape reflexes
that involve different what
are called command neurons that
get sensory input and
drive motor output.
And one of these
particular neurons
is where this effect about
inhibition was first shown.
It's called the LG.
LG neurons, MG neurons that
drive two different kinds
of escape reflexes.
So here are the two different
kinds of escape reflexes.
The medial giant neuron
drives the MG escape,
which is if you touch
the crayfish on its nose,
it flicks its tail
and goes backwards.
The LG escape is when you
touch the crayfish on its tail,
and it flicks its tail in a
way that makes it go forward.
OK?
So let's look at what
those behaviors look like.
We're going to post this video.
This is from a Journal
of Visual Experiments.
And there's a nice-- it's
actually really nice--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The recordings of neural
and muscular field potentials,
electronic recordings from
a pair of bath electrodes
are synchronized with high speed
video recordings and display--
MICHALE FEE: So this
video shows you actually
how to set up a
tank with electrodes
so you can record the
signals from these neurons
in a crayfish while
it's behaving.
So you should watch the video.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHALE FEE: But I'm
going to show you--
I'm going to show you what--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Here is a look at a series
of single, high speed video
frames and corresponding
electric field
recordings for an escape
tail flip in response to--
MICHALE FEE: Can you hear that?
- A stimulus delivered
to the head or tail
of a juvenile crayfish.
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHALE FEE: So that
was the MG response.
And he puts two
electrodes into the tank.
And you can actually
measure signals
in the tank from
that neuron firing.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- The giant neuron and the
phasic deflection that follows
enables non-ambiguous
identification of the tail flip
as mediated by giant
neuron activity.
The backward movement
shown in the video traces
determines the identity of
the activated neural circuit.
Here is a tail flip
mediated by the--
MICHALE FEE: So here, you
touch him on the tail--
- Tactile stimulus was
applied to the tail.
Upward and forward motion--
MICHALE FEE: You can see it
a different movement that
makes him--
- Synchronized electronic trace,
displaying the giant spike
and the large phasic
initial deflection
determines the identity of
the activated neural circuit.
This video demonstrates the--
MICHALE FEE: Here's a
different escape reflex
that doesn't involve either
of those two neurons.
Here he spends a
little more time
thinking before he
figures out what to do.
- A giant spike and
consists of much--
[END PLAYBACK]
MICHALE FEE: OK.
All right, so let me just--
I probably won't get very far in
explaining the inhibition part,
but you can at least
understand a little bit more
about this behavior.
So what's really cool
is that inhibition
is used to regulate
these two behaviors.
So the idea is that--
so first let me just
say that kind of that
LG neuron, that
lateral giant neuron,
is known as a command neuron.
And that is because if you
activate that neuron, if you
just depolarize that one neuron,
it activates that entire escape
reflex.
And if you hyperpolarize
that neuron,
inhibit that neuron,
you completely
suppress the escape reflex.
And now, what's
really interesting
is that that neuron has
inhibitory inputs that
control the probability that the
animal will elicit this escape
reflex.
And that kind of
modulation of that behavior
is really interesting.
And it has some interesting
subtleties to it.
So first of all, if
the animal is touched
on the nose and elicits--
touched on the nose and elicits
an MG response, the tail flips
and the animal goes
backwards, right?
But now, if it goes backwards
and it bumps into something
on his backside, when
it's going backwards,
you don't want to
have that immediately
trigger an LG escape, and
he bumps into something.
He's like boom,
boom, boom, right?
That would be terrible.
So what happens is that when the
MG neuron fires and initiates
that backwards movement,
it sends a signal that
inhibits the LG response.
OK?
OK, other cool things, when
the animal is restrained,
when you pick the animal
up, if he doesn't get away
from you with his first escape
attempt and you hold him,
you can touch him
on the nose and it
won't elicit an escape reflex.
So when the animal is held,
the response probability
goes way down.
Maybe he's like
holding off until he
feels like your grip loosen a
little bit and then he'll try.
OK?
So there's no point in
wasting escape attempts.
They're very
energetically expensive,
wasting escape attempts when
you're being restrained.
Another interesting
modulation is
that the LG escape
response is suppressed
while the animal is eating.
This is threshold.
This is how much you
have to poke in the nose
or in the tail for
him to escape when
he's just wandering around.
But then while he's
eating, he's getting food.
And so the threshold for
eliciting that escape reflex
goes up.
He's like, sorry, I'm eating.
Leave me alone.
OK?
It's not just being
hungry, right?
Because if he's hungry
and searching for food,
there's no increased threshold.
So it's really
because he's eating.
He's found a food source.
He doesn't want to leave it.
So there's a higher--
he won't leave until
there's like more danger.
So all this different kinds
of modulation and inhibition
of the behavior is controlled
by inhibitory [AUDIO OUT]
projecting onto this LG neuron.
So there are two kinds
of escape modulation.
One is absolute.
When the animal is engaged
in an escape reflex,
it is impossible to activate--
when the animal is engaged
in an MG escape, it's impossible
to activate the LG escape.
No matter how much he
gets poked in the tail,
he will not initiate an LG.
So this kind of
modulation is absolute.
There's this other
kind of modulation,
where the likelihood of
escape is just reduced,
but the animal is still
able to initiate escape
if the danger is high enough,
if the stimulus is high enough.
And that's really the
crux of the difference
is that some kinds of
suppression of a behavior
are absolute.
No matter how strong
the stimulus is,
you don't want to allow
that neuron to spike.
In the other case
is I'm just going
to turn down the
probability that I generate
[AUDIO OUT] because I'm eating.
But if it's looks dangerous
enough I'm still going to go.
But I'm just going to modulate,
gently, the probability.
And it turns out that's
the crux of the difference.
So it turns out the LG neuron
has two sites on it where
you get sources of inhibition.
There are a bunch
of inhibitory inputs
on the proximal dendrite
near the spike initiation
zone, which is right here.
And that's recurrent
inhibition, because it's coming
from the other escape neuron.
So it's recurrent
within the motor system.
And the other inhibitory
synapses come out here
on the dendrite.
And they're [AUDIO OUT]
higher brain areas.
And it's called tonic inhibition
for historical reasons.
Now, previous hypothesis
was that those inputs here
allowed inhibition to
control different branches
of the input.
But it turns out the
answer is very simple.
So let me just summarize this.
So you have one [AUDIO OUT]
input, inhibitory input,
that's coming from the
other escape neuron
that lands right there on
the part of this neuron
the initiates spikes.
The other input that suppresses
the response during feeding
is coming far out on the
dendrite at the same location
where those excitatory
inputs, the sensory inputs,
are coming in.
So that's what the
circuit looks like.
So the input that
absolutely suppresses
the response of this neuron
is coming right on the soma,
right where the
spike is generated.
And the ones that
tonic [AUDIO OUT]
sort of adjust the
probability of spiking
are coming out here where
the excitatory inputs are.
And so they developed the
simple equivalent circuit model
where they have a
dendrite out here.
Out here on the dendrite,
you have an excitatory input.
And you can have recurrent
input on the soma.
And there's another model.
So in one of these
models, they're
modeling the
proximal inhibition.
In the other model, they put
the inhibitory synapse out here
on the dendrite.
And they ask, how are those two
different sources of inhibition
different?
What do they do
differently to the neuron?
And they just did this model.
They analyzed it
mathematically, exactly
like the way I just showed you.
That very simple
calculation works.
You just use
Kirchhoff's current law.
And you write down
the voltage response
to the excitatory
synapse as a function
of the strength of these two
different kinds of inhibition.
And here's what you find.
The proximal inhibition
suppresses the response
to the excitatory input
by the same fraction
no matter how strong
the excitation is.
So if you put in
strong inhibition,
you can always cause
that excitatory input
to be suppressed to zero.
So inhibitory input
approximately at the soma
can suppress the response of a
neuron to an excitatory input,
no matter how strong
the excitatory input is.
On the other hand,
inhibition out
on the dendrite for any
given amount of inhibition,
there's always an
excitation that's
strong enough to allow the
response to get through.
So this shows the
amount of suppression
as a function of
excitatory input.
And you can see that no matter
how strong the inhibition,
there's always an amount
of excitation that
will overcome the inhibition.
And you can also
do that analysis
in a much more
complicated model.
And you get exactly
the same results.
But what's really
cool is that you
can understand this
just from this very
simple two-compartment model.
And I wish I had a
little bit more time
to go through those models
and explain why that works.
But basically, proximal
inhibition is absolute.
You can always make
the inhibition win.
Distal inhibition kind of
gently varies the effect
of the excitatory input.
All right, so that's what we
covered-- synapses, a model,
convolution,
synaptic saturation,
and the different functions of
distal and proximal inhibition.